it's actually hilarious people losing
weight that guy's your brother that's
the property brothers Jonathan and drew
Scott reacting to the Internet's
interest in this pick all three Scott
brothers together the third one
JD short for James Daniel is actually
Jonathan and Drew's big bro
so JD's two years older but he looks
younger cuz he's a measly six-foot to a
little guy no and anyways everyone else
thought he was our younger brother
chances are you've actually seen JD on
one of the brothers HGTV shows he's been
in most of our shows yeah yeah I mean JD
also he's a handy guy I mean he also has
been flipping houses working on houses
he he's been a host for years and so
that's why we like to work together we
always do the three of us are thick as
thieves
he's the email contractor yeah he's like
the doc hair and all that he actually
used to be an Adam Lambert impersonator
he's a performer we're a performing
family our parents were the same and I
think that's the most that's why we have
so much fun working together and
actually JD's girlfriend is makeup
artist on our shows and I know his job
his girlfriend works with our company my
girlfriend's a creative director with
our company so we are very tight mixed
well speaking of performing Jonathan and
drew do have a new singing gig
the brothers have partnered with
assurance for a series of home hack
Diddy's they were hilarious and they
were musical and we have different
genres that we're coming out with whose
face cleaned Oh head lice
[Music]
you